i think brennan we have to uh at least
talk about this
um you guys if you follow the news if
you're alive
uh if you've been following this twitter
thing the way
we have uh you know what's going on with
our friend chris
i'm not you know that when these
situations
people in hollywood tell you what to say
and um i i i said to brennan what we can
do is tell the truth
and i'm not going to sit here i'm a man
and i define myself on how i
respond to these situations in real time
when the pressure's
really on and so this is what i'll say
i always knew chris as a ladies man i
have never
and i'm gonna say this i have never seen
or heard
of him doing anything illegal ever
this is as shocking to me as i'm
watching this happen
i don't know what to think and i don't
know what to say
i don't but i have
i'm going to say it again i have
personally never heard
or seen him do anything illegal
that's all i can say and right now i
have to believe that
because he's still a friend and and it
may be unpopular to say that but
i i don't know what else to say i don't
know what else to do
and i'm not going to be i'm not going to
be some uh i i i just think it's an
impossible situation
and uh i'm i'm just at a loss i'm at a
loss
and i'm praying i'm praying that um
what i'm hearing isn't true maybe that's
the best way to put it
i can't talk it's just
you know it's like it's a weird thing
because i said
to brennan i said it's like um you know
it's it's like watching someone die or
something
and also it's just
you know it's important to say we
haven't spoken to chris no
and we've never been we've never been on
the road with him i you know i was on
the road with him
um about 14 years ago once um
when he was you know just beginning but
i've never been on the road with him so
i don't know
i don't know i don't know what to think
and i don't know and that's what's so
frustrating
it's i'm just sad yeah i'm sad i don't
so anyway
yeah sometimes that's the best thing to
say
is to say i don't know what to say and
i'm just um
i don't know man yeah it's a it's it's a
[ __ ] up thing i can't talk
[ __ ] well that's appropriate that's
appropriate right now
you can just you can just pray that
that nothing's true because no matter
what the facts are whatever comes out
i'm as shocked as anyone i'm hurt i'm
mad i'm
i'm [ __ ] mad man i'm mad at him
okay